in the snow-capped mountains of the moon
standing high above the rich lands of
the Vale stands the Eyrie
a storied and impregnable fortress said
to have been built by the legendary
mountain kings in the Age of Heroes
it is the stronghold of house Aaron one
of the oldest noble families in Westeros
their sigil a soaring Falcon over a
crescent moon their words as high as
honour the Aaron's are direct
descendants of Andal invaders who sailed
across the Narrow Sea and came ashore at
the fingers
according to legend Sir artists Aron
known as the winged Knight soared
through the sky atop a giant Falcon
landing on the peak of the highest
mountain where he defeated the Gryphon
King in battle
it was the Andals first great victory
over the first men and so artists was
duly rewarded he was declared king of
the mountain and the Vale and the region
was renamed the Vale of Arryn thousands
of years later Aegon the Conqueror
arrived in Westeros house Aaron bent the
knee to a gan and his dragons and were
allowed to maintain the control of the
region as Lords paramount of the rail
and wardens of the east over the
centuries house
Aaron remained loyal to the Targaryen
dynasty until Lord Jon Arryn joined with
houses Baratheon and Stark in rebellion
against Mad King Aerys
upon winning the Iron Throne Robert
named Lord John hand of the King a
position he held until his mysterious
death